[Music]
you
Tony Thomas CIO of Nissan welcome to
Stanford University and systems
leadership thank you I tell us a little
bit about your job in the company now
that you've been there nine months sure
so I joined us the CIO for Nissan I have
primarily three aspects to my job first
and foremost is run the traditional IT
yesterday that we have across the brands
divisions and the region's second is to
drive the digital transformation that
Nissan is undergoing because of the
changes in the automotive industry and
last but not the least is about building
a set of talent that can enable us to
thrive in the digital environment that
we are at alright so let's talk about
the second one for a second how are the
changes in the mobility industry
impacting you and your job at Nissan
it's actually very interesting and when
you think about it because first and
foremost the buying model is changing
more towards ecommerce rather than the
traditional way of going to the dealers
and you know looking at the car at the
dealers and making a decision then I'm
there second is about the connected
services as we call it so cars have
become an extension of your persona in
some form then of course you know about
the autonomous and the electric the
other piece is that we are working on if
you really look at the e-commerce models
it's predominantly coming from my team
because it's a you know it's a digital
the IT aspects that are driving it
services a lot of capabilities come from
our team because it's all driven from
the need of the customer knowing the
customer the customer relationship but
all the four things that I talked about
in a way at the end of the day is driven
through data data of the of the car from
the car of the customer I bought the
customer behaviors usage etc so all in
all I think you know my team is front
and center of this transformation that
is going on so as you think about the
customer experience how do you think
about the actions and activities of
legacy competitors Toyota Volkswagen GM
versus new up stars like Tesla yeah so I
honestly do not know I haven't done a
full study of all that so but but for me
coming from companies like Vodafone or
Citibank you know where where consumer
experience is something that we thrive
for for me the way I look at it is that
how can be as a company put the best set
of information in front of our customers
so that they can see what products are
available what can they afford or how
can we help
afford how do they configure how will
they buy the right car how do the
service of the be managed so to me it's
about that into an relationship that
360-degree view for the customer that we
can provide and again you know I've not
really seen case studies where car
companies are being used as the best
examples but but from a potential
perspective you know that's our
opportunity what's it been like for you
to come into a large mobility company
like Nissan and not be from the mobility
industry I think for me at least I look
at it as a strength because like I said
I've seen other industries very much
I've been in telcos I've been in banks
I've been in heavy manufacturing so for
me you know the strengths that I bring
from these companies and today's
automotive industry is not a monolithic
automotive manufacturing company the
connected services we talked about the
autonomous we talked about a lot of
telco capabilities are there the
customer experience that customers are
looking for comes from the consumer
world and the banks the regulations the
security so I think you know what what
today's automotive industry is a
culmination of all those consumer
segments that I worked in and the
industrial segments that I worked in as
well so you've been there now nine
months what are the top two or three
things where you're spending your time
and how did you determine that those are
the areas where you need to be yeah so
in my case you know when we talk about
digital transformation which is
important for us it beyond the
traditional running of IT we need to do
three things well first and foremost
have the right set of platforms that can
manage the data store the data and
transport the data the second is about
having the right environment for our
people to thrive in be it in my team be
the manufacturing folks visa sales folks
and last but not the least is about
having a team who are more an agile a
quick win type of development
environment that we can that we can have
in so to me it's it's in those three
areas the platform's the the workplace
and the skills that we're looking for
you talked about your time at GE and
Vodafone and City what's been the
biggest difference that you have found
perhaps unexpectedly of being inside of
a company like Nissan I think to me you
know when you are joining Nissan you
know it's a Japanese company that you
know it and you you you you you come to
think about certain
aspects of the company but when I came
here what surprised me was that what do
you know about the company from outside
and what I'm seeing from inside it's a
lot of difference because the company
being very humble in its nature a lot of
the good things that we are doing is not
really visible to the market other than
through the products themselves so I
think to me that's an opportunity that I
as a CIO can help bridge as well some of
the big products that we are coming up
with through our intelligent mobility
autonomous driving etcetera all the
people you know although we have the
best cars in electric vehicles you know
you're not talking about Nissan as the
pioneer you know we have been a lot of
people are using other brands as the
pioneer in that so to me I think that is
the surprise that I found coming from
outside in but when I look from inside
and I'm like wow you know I'm surprised
in a positive way everyday and lastly
how does your group interact with what
I'll call the traditional product group
inside of Nissan the people who have
decades and decades of expertise of
designing cars and building cars at
scale and now you're bringing a digital
perspective on it how has that
interaction gone yeah so we are changing
the dynamics hopefully worried in the
old days it was more about an
order-taker
you know we used to take a chunk of work
we used to build it somehow and we used
to return it they would look at what we
built
sometimes it meets the expectations
sometimes it doesn't but we are changing
that model we are building you know more
of more of a bit of ports or team of
teams or mission based teams whereby you
know both the product teams the the
customer in the scenario and I also sit
together and we build it and in a very
short cycle rather than long projects so
in that sense you know there's no
ownership that is better understanding
there is better you know quick you know
speed to delivery etc that we need to
win so today's session in the class is
leading through uncertainty and I can't
think of anybody who's come as and
guests in our class who was going
through more uncertainty in his industry
than you are so Tony thank you very much
for coming to Stanford we really
appreciate your time thank you for the
opportunity really enjoy that thank you
you